what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
today House of the Dragon
dracaris John how's the flame in your
loins it is bright and and burn and
how's your loin doing it's it is a it's
I gotta get a check by a doctor ladies
and gentlemen strike that like button I
know you can doesn't take much effort on
your hands please go ahead and do it
also subscribe click that notification
Bell to get notified when our reaction
for the finale of House of the Dragons
up here on the channel also uh
full-length Reaction watch along is
resync with your own copy available for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
thank you so much to everyone who has
joined but more importantly thank you to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video
that is the VPN that we actually use
here at Zario rejects so it makes for
the most natural Partnerships and will
tell you why we like to use them
specifically after the reaction anyway
let's get to it
[Music]
oh is this like right after viserys died
with his own eyes you guys
stay here tell them tell no one
who knows
I have made him tell you
some of the servants he's the Spy right
last night she told me you wish for egg
on to be king oh [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the king is dead
but he has left us a gift
with his last breath he impressed upon
the queen his final wish that his son
should succeed him oh no the Seven
Kingdoms
like immediately tell the council I have
known this errors longer than any who
sit at this table
and I will not believe that he said this
on his death bed alone with only the
boy's mother as a witness thank you yeah
the King was well last night
my whole account
which of you here can swim
that he died of his own accord
whether it was one of you or all of you
oh my God I care not I will have no
thoughts whoa
oh my God that's taken care of throw
down your sword and remove your cloaks
of Kristen
I am your lord command as a Christian I
will not suffer insults to how Grace the
queen there was no insult to me
you decide your blade this is such an
upsetting conversation
yeah everyone's true colors coming out
for my rare cannot of course be allowed
to remain free and draw support to her
claim
you mean to imprison
she and her family will be given the
opportunity to publicly swear a basement
to the new king oh you scum your father
is correct your grace
living Challenger invites battle and
bloodshed and War will happen
it's coming where you like it or not the
king wouldn't wish for any of them wish
for the murder of his daughter
yeah he loved her I'll not have you
denied this
word and I'll have you removed from this
chamber and sent to the wall yeah
crush your head on the spot Lord
Commander westerling take your Knights
the Dragonstone be quick and be clean
and until that is one I have no place
here
does he get to collect unemployment
she's going to naturally get promoted
now
where is that going
[Music]
not here
he's not in his rooms
he's probably doing something very
admirable right now I believe he may
have left the keep Secret
gone into the city
find him
bring him to me and me alone Sir Eric
map this plan out for so long puppet
master I really didn't expect it to just
kick off like this
[Music]
I'm gonna have to keep a close eye on
all of you until this is sorted out
oh
this is so so disturbing
I've had the worst worst kind of
negative nipple chills this entire time
I'll come with you
that would not be my desire amen
Cole needs me mother
so Eric isn't the only one who knows
acorns doing he's very inconspicuous
look at him he'll blend right in right
in want to hear eye patch
the prince is not here has he been here
Dahlia perhaps quite a bit earlier
years ago in fact more recently it is
not frequent the street of silk his
tastes are known to be less
discriminating
oh I wish you luck good sir
and my best to your friend
how you've grown
nature remembers all
the series amended his
I just wanna you once wore your Banners
To renira I don't know what I want to do
but you want to do it and you want to do
it best
I must confer first with my house on
this matter
you'll not leave this room without
declaring your intention
you are such a prick
he's loyal to an error I am no oath
breaker I will not bend the knee how
well
what a crock of [ __ ]
please this way to execute you
single file
oh he's bending the knee Oh I thought
you were the good one as long as the
king
[Music]
you're doing so good for sarath you're
just so good
I couldn't
hear the whole thing up
he's in an underground Fight Club
down
come here come back
[Music]
he isn't an underground Fight Club
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
little kids come on they have to grow
their nails and file the teeth oh my God
spends many a night in this place
[Applause]
[Music]
my God
one of many had wager
wow holy moly that is so twisted
[Music]
all right guys Team Green at the real
Rejects
bend the knee what can I have no choice
now we're in I just like saying that to
upset you desire who trains with the
sword who rides the largest dragon in
the world desires you should be
yeah I know what it is to toil for what
others have really given
and we can't find him Cole be our decent
man with no taste for depravity
all right are we
oh something must be done oh my God is
he gonna report he's got a crisis of
conscience brewing a moment of your time
Lords
you'll find no buyers for your words
here
I think you've been
seen spotted you know what I mean
[Music]
all right up man
I know oh
oh I have no love for the princess
where were you going then it's such
urgency
let the king's Justice take him
come on man you had like 10 minutes to
think of a lie
[Music]
you know I'm trying to hate her but I
just feel bad I know everyone hates her
so much and everyone's using her in one
way or another like jeez
[Music]
she really did love him
[Music]
or have a love for him yeah she must now
finish his model of old valyria I just
want to check in with renera make sure
she's okay and
how's valarian has long Allied itself
with the princess rhaenyra and what has
it gained you
the word of my house is not
no true Queen
let's make a window in the wall of your
prison
wait where is this going
oh what that's turn
have a ring the bell when you have an
answer have a Queens to be Battle Royale
it's gonna be like when Arnold ran for
governor
everyone's gonna want to be on that
yep you yourself are the mysterious
white worm I take it or are you simply a
further people in this stinking onion my
condolence is
nicely done where's the prince
oh nice you go close to the bribes given
them to look away
and obscenity either tolerated or
ignored by the crown you just went up
100 points in my book lady I look into
it
you have my work
that's not much of a word
[Music]
God this kid
oh this is so embarrassing
I do regret this friend
oh wow dang oh god
[Music]
oh yeah yep I was hoping you disappeared
does our father truly dead yes and
they're going to make you king oh damn
where's your brother
let me go he's got the best seat he's up
there
there are so many people watching
the queen always
[Laughter]
[Music]
we have not seen Rainier at all why are
they gone
deep now is icy
nicely done I am rooting for Allison in
this particular situation
and it's a nuanced perspective
Mr will be named Lord commander of the
king's God of course he is my son was
hit the crown of his namesake the
Conqueror and Carrie Blackfire his sword
the people remember the ancient strength
of House Targaryen
bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
bad
bad
you look so much like your mother in
certain lights
before Otto killed her
plot twist
is so awful
Damon get in there sliced it all down
more than once it is proved advantageous
to those willing to
feed the Weaver
this is whoa whoa decency
oh
no sir
[Music]
a lot of the men in this show make me
want to throw up
yeah
absolutely
with me princess
oh what poor guy the black water's this
way
[Music]
bad feeling about this
[Music]
such [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my God is this really happening right
now
we have 20 years
mind
I still don't want like common sense
right now
with his final breath he whispered to me
that you
this is so frustrating
and all this it's just like one child
misunderstanding at least let him pass
it off to Eamon
and then when he's when's he gonna be
informed of the prophecy and all that
stuff
yeah that's a good question who's gonna
tell them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow for as his Spirit left us
he whispered his final wish that his
first born son aegon
should succeed him
this man is so bad his cats went so fast
oh [ __ ] you knew it though yeah
[Music]
damn you elephant
[Music]
and privilege
wow
Goosebumps everywhere that is so messed
up this is so bad
[Music]
huh
I just feel like Bruno's being wrong so
harshly right now
okay the Crone lift a shining lamp and
light his way to wisdom
oh my God what's race gonna do the crown
of the Conqueror passed down through
generations
story gets lost over time
and here we are let the seven bear
Witness
egg on Targaryen is the true heir to the
iron throne
the tiniest nod lord of the Seven
Kingdoms and protector of the realm
egg on the king
please clap
[Applause]
[Applause]
God damn you Allison
[Applause]
[Music]
damn you are
oh yeah now you're starting to like this
[Music]
oh we are going to have a full on war in
season two
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about yeah
yeah
oh yes
fly fly away damn
[Music]
show her riding him come on show her
come on
[Applause]
yes oh my god did you see that look when
she was in the crowd like I'm gonna mess
it up here burn it all
[Music]
wow what a badass
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude MVP
foreign
all right there is so much to talk about
before we do
gotta think
expressvpn because they're loyal and
they don't want to dick us over like how
this Situation's gone down thank you to
expressvpn for sponsoring this video
guys listen I'm gonna go straight to the
chase here if you're using the internet
in the year of 2022 you ought to be
using it with the protection of a VPN
and before I go into the protection part
let me tell you why we first got a VPN
all right it was just for the this
purpose alone you know I was always
hearing like YouTubers people talking
about how they were able to access
Netflix in the UK and other things like
that via a VPN and they would have
different properties on there than that
of the US and it worked it's amazing I
love the access to it
in the world to do absolutely and right
now Express is ranked number one
Business Insider and it works across all
your devices that includes Smart TV
which is perfect for checking out Geo
lock content from all over the world
thanks to Express's Global array of
services then yeah like I said that's
literally the first thing we did when we
activated our account they got servers
on all across the world so you can pick
and choose literally where you want to
be surfing from for your own safety or
just to check out that content whatever
it is but either way there's always
someone out there looking to swipe or
trade your information and half the time
it's your own ISP actively trading your
information to other advertising
companies which is perfectly legal
America America yeah so fortunately you
can stop all that and we have had a we
had a really scary situation happen to
us a while ago so we did actually need
an expressvpn for our own protection as
well so you can protect your data 100 we
really do vouch for this and yeah you
can enjoy some cool perks while in the
process of using expressvpn as well so
to put simply and I had John write this
down for me uh Express it's an app it
reroutes your Internet connection
through a selection of secure servers
from all over the world encrypting your
information and keeping it hidden from
anyone who's trying to steal or spy on
it uh thank you for writing that for me
I don't know why you could have just
read it yourself but I appreciate you
writing that down I'm just jealous that
you got to read why don't you read down
what I wrote absolutely and if you would
like to reap all those lovely benefits
and get an extra three months for free
on a one year package let me tell you
visit our exclusive link which is
expressvpn.com rejects that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s Greg was adamant that I
spell it for you uh.com VPN spell V with
a p and an A as in Victor p is in
pineapples and N is in nacho cheese take
too long to think of what that letter is
rejects that's our code
rejects learn more anyway do it look
back to talking about how's the drive
wow what a what a cool episode you don't
cut to renero or Damon once this entire
time
this whole time you're just like whoa
they're gonna rack like when the fun
yeah don't ruin it for me in this
comments you bastards in Texas so it's
just gonna be 20 minutes of Rainier and
screaming what I have successfully
avoided spoilers for this so yeah I
think I'm ruined [ __ ] for me uh yeah
that that was a very tense gripping
episode and so conflicting because
you're thrusted into
perspectives here that you know is just
not true but then you're kind of find
yourself it's like you could either just
play on the sidelines and observe or you
can start kind of adopting a perspective
here and you know it's like off of
course I don't agree with all with what
happened
um but I thought one of the most um
enriching emotional tolls that they
managed to ring out of this given
situation was you're like God damn it
Allison you don't know what you're
talking about you know you don't know
what happened but then when it came time
to like find aegon and the conversation
that she has with rainey's rainey's
sorry that's how I say it rainey's it's
a conversation that she has with her you
know it's like you do find her going but
I wanted to take like some kind of stand
against Otto because he's been a real
dick and a lot of this has been uh his
manipulation pulling the strings so I'm
like if this is gonna happen she should
at least have ownership over the
situation you know and I do have it done
her way
so you do have that compelling side
because at least in though I have not
read the book so at least in the way it
is Illustrated here in this series
I understand where she's coming from all
right do I agree no am I on her side
absolutely not
but she does think she's honoring
viserys's dying wish
and that's the part where you're like
well if that's the way you think and
feel and believe this right now
um and I understand why you think that
given the circumstances you were being
dealt here with Otto Hightower I I I see
why why you feel that all right
all right so then back to the
conversation
um
all right that was rear camera just cut
randomly okay sorry about that anyway uh
as we're talking I'm Gonna Leave just
that I'm really gonna try and marry the
the clips properly I'm just gonna leave
the fact that the camera got here is
that we're all the footage it says
um so yeah when you have this
conversation this debate I find myself
like you know I feel bad for her because
she clearly
it's it's such a fascinating seat to be
in from I feel like book readers have no
issue I mean like no screwels you know
yeah totally the way I hear it's every
impression I've heard no sympathy
whatsoever don't trust her no matter
what they do on the show don't trust her
well I feel like they're gonna make her
worse you can just feel that happening
you know like she is morphing and
morphing over time and then in in some
ways with rainey's of how she sort of
empowers
um uh Allison in this moment and even at
the very tail end with the show-off or
she could have just been like you guys
are a bunch of sacks of [ __ ] I'm going
to pursue on the flames right now she
didn't there was even a little bit of
exchange of
there's a bit of admiration in what you
just did but uh I'm flying off right
you played the game well game recognized
games but also I'm getting the hell out
of here yeah follow me if you want
Randy's almost looked at the camera and
was like welcome to the Game of Thrones
flew off you don't got the stomach for
it get out now
uh
and then yeah there's so many different
compelling factors here because like
Auto a Hightower is just morphing into
full-on bulging red eyes guys yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah and just watching
like I love the way he plays that
character because it's like it's the
more we experience his strategy and his
actions the the greater the argument
becomes for like never ever trusting a
single emotional beat that comes out of
him and I I think he's a fascinating
character due to that he comes back to
that thing of just trying to act in the
best interests of the realm and all that
stuff and there are parts of me that
kind of still believe that but yeah like
he oh screw that now
yeah a bunch of [ __ ] like he wasn't
plotting that forever yeah yeah and I
mean he seems like the kind of guy who
wants to be the de facto King you know
and it was it was almost a sorry I have
to interrupt it was almost as if
when Allison
revealed the king's dying wish that
everyone on that Council who was Stephen
was like
[ __ ] what did we think to just say that
when he died
wow he did the rest of the planning for
us we could have just said he whispered
this yeah we could have done this
anytime what is wrong with us in fact we
could have just locked him up killed him
ourselves said he did that and then
passed it off his natural causes what is
wrong with us yeah yeah one it Clues you
in like what's so great about this
episode across the board but especially
what's so maddening about this exact
situation is yeah it is like it's so
human and in this period of time
especially like it's all word against
word against account against account and
so it's no wonder they do everything so
fast because it's like you expect me to
bleed like I love you pointed that out
like even uh aegon sorry seems to be the
one guy who's like really Mom Dad said
this right before he died and no one was
there really
um but yeah like like the the mistake
made you know he he misjudges who's with
him and that leads to all this and and
then again you know like all these
little fragile again perceptions and
convictions that make up the real
tapestry of what this is so easy to
focus on the action and yet certain of
the most pivotal moments come from just
little human errors and I think that's
really beautiful and really imagining
and really fascinating and it makes for
like really tense storytelling because
it it contributes to that idea that
anything could happen see because I just
for some reason my mind went
after last week's episode which by the
way
I gotta love comments who were like I
think you were confused on what happened
at the end there and then if there were
people where I was like if you just
waited 40 seconds literally yeah like 30
to 40 seconds you would have seen no I
said exactly what you said in that
comment and more
I was not confused
appreciate appreciate you looking out
though I will say it wasn't mean
spirited I don't want to act like you
guys are being dicks like you guys are
actually like wait it might be confused
you know
um my own ego was just getting like what
the [ __ ] is I did get it you know
because sometimes you feel like you want
that credit you want the credit for
getting stuff
um so but now no one was a dick about it
they were actually if they were actually
trying to clarify in case I forgot in
case we didn't understand
um but no I would completely understand
what happened I was under the impression
that there was going to be like like a
debate about what to do I didn't think
it was gonna be he said that all right
activate Planet
activate operation a God on the throne
we've been plotting this for the past 10
years and all we needed was this one
moment yeah yeah did not think that's
how it was gonna go I thought it was
gonna be like a an episode of like
discussion and and some type of because
yeah they had the debate at the
beginning with the council and and I
liked the position Allison took screw it
all right I love the way Allison's
written in the show I think she's
running great all right and I'm very
very much drawn to her character like I
don't it's an interesting position it's
an honest room to be like I'm so not on
your side but I completely get why you
think the way you're thinking and why
you're doing what you're doing you know
like I I I do really love the way she's
written and it's not even like I love to
hate you kind of relationship yeah it's
like I I get you even though I just
don't agree with you
um
but she was even like that she's so
about because you you do explore that
she still has a moral compass to us to
an extent everyone in the Game of
Thrones world has that aspect of to an
extent all right and she has still that
feeling of really she loved viserys and
she wanted to honor she wants to
understand which and she was even like I
don't feel like we should go behind her
I'm not I don't want to like she had
that contemplate At first she had that
contemplation we gotta do this now
but she did have that contemplation of I
got you know like viserys wouldn't want
she didn't want rhaenyra to die period
plain and simple she didn't want renera
executed even though did he go behind
her back and did this whole thing that's
the part that's so like frustrating it's
like it's not even a conversation
happening about this she didn't want
rhaenyra to die and she had reasoning
from her own personal feelings of
whatever nostalgic feelings but also on
like knowing viserys wouldn't want
rhaenery to die Mr Family Man Mr like
dying moment
it's painful to watch it's an emotion
it's it's weirdly consistent emotional
episode as tense and taught as it is
it's weirdly emotional because you know
this is not what viceros wanted like you
know as an audience member what the
truth is you know he did not want this
and you it's just knowing where he left
off of like I think I did what I wanted
which was unite my family and
everything's gonna be fine and because
of a misunderstanding
yeah because he spoke to the wrong
person because I saw the wrong person in
the dark yeah my one good eyes blind
spot yeah because he messed that up it's
now gonna cause a big war the pacifist
he's not right the ultimate irony he's
leaving these gay people call him
peaceful peaceful yeah
um it it's painful to watch and then
there's all kinds of people who want us
to strip that Throne you know like Chris
Christian's gone all like uh yeah broke
my heart finally yeah that's his whole
performance now yeah yeah I'm loyalty
ulcerer's ready to kill him
yeah I know everything he does you
brought my heart from her like he ran
off of me completely defined his whole
existence since then the whole yeah now
his whole goal is just to back the high
tower regime and to see renera suffer as
much as possible yeah
yeah well and again like it's it's all
it's it's so beautiful because it's yeah
it's you get steeped in all these
personal elements and angles and I love
when they're out in the city looking for
aegon and you have these two pairs
you're watching as Sir Eric and his
brother you know conduct one way and
you're watching as two people who we
don't know as personally are processing
the sort of debate that this represents
and then you have two people who are
like totally on the inside of the debate
in
aymond and Kristen who are looking for
aegon and the way that that whole
convergence comes and watching as aegon
is like dragged back to uh King's
Landing and you know forced to do this
and part part way through you know like
the dagger has I believe the the
prophecy on it uh but part of me was
like I don't know I feel like maybe
he'll just kill himself or something
like that because he was really not into
this but then you also watch that turn
as he finally sees his court and all the
people and everyone begins to applaud
him and you can see how so it's it's
that fascinating I can't remember
exactly what the line was but but
something about you know not being
grateful because of these things that
are sort of just like made available to
you when other people have to work for
them and so as as much of a depraved
sort of amoral characters we know aegon
to be I'm fascinated to see where this
will take him because if there's one
thing that's made him sort of
fascinating to me it's that he doesn't
seem to care and he actively seems to
reject the throne and so now that he's
got it and now that he's got this taste
of you know uh Power and this just this
taste of you know getting the sense for
how much he Lords over uh I I am
terrified to see what that character
becomes and then also what that does to
amend because I mean part of me was like
yeah this is that's that other thing of
like he's clearly capable and wants to
do it so why not why did the rules
dictate things that could only be aegon
yeah uh yeah and it's all these yeah
like there's so many great elements of
here's how our system works and here's
how we need to uphold it but also here
all the little personal aspects that
you know gum up the gears and everything
and yeah the the machinations are wild
and and it's fascinating to me the way
that they're able to balance those two
out because you always feel the huge
Stakes but you always feel the very
small micro personal Stakes kind of
always percolating between the two in
every given moment while you even have
now
it always seemed like there was some
type of loyalist relationship with Otto
and Allison you're like oh it's them
going Toe to Toe now now they're skiing
against each other she's tired of being
a pawn and she's going to oh my God the
pervert's name
yeah oh God and Lauren it's like Lars
was what Otto was doing you know okay
and now Otto's like out now
drunk on his own plan but he was always
like mine just
I'm a little Coy about everything I
don't know I mean I mean I could kill I
don't want to kill the White Worm but I
could if you wanted him yeah
your dad is really helpful to your dad
and Lars is uh he he's he's just uh he
he really is repulsive he's a very
repulsive character yeah and
um these like weird sexual exchanges
that he has with the queen uh or like
like these voyeuristic sexual exchanges
like nasty and he said like I wouldn't
want him to meet the actor
if I saw him I'd be like oh my God it's
that guy from a house of the Dragon I'm
gonna say hi I'm like no I don't want to
say hi to the guy let's take a different
route let's let's leave the store I will
not be able to see past who he plays
he could be like hi my name is uh wow
what are you doing Ken Walters and I
play uh Lars it was a real hard
character to get into and mastering that
accident on the show very difficult but
uh I think I nailed it with my voice
acting coach oh yeah that's a nice pair
of sandals you've got on you seem like
you keep your feet real well trimmed I
would not be able to see past the
reaction place oh no yeah this you know
that he's got more more pawns up his
sleeve he's just playing now he plays a
slow Slytherin chess game and then you
know 100 meters from now they've got
like a little finger
there's always there's just it's you're
just kind of watching this generational
cycle of like this one wants thrown this
one is little skeeving guy who serves
the hierarchy this one is I don't want a
part of it but I'm going to be a big
part of it you know and everyone's got
their own little archetypes here yeah
and who among the people who can't have
the throne but really really want it
will get closest and and Whisper the
most poison into whoever's ear
so this was uh this was a fascinating
tale and
um I thought reynus was a freaking
awesome after everything she's been
through I thought that was such a
cathartic moment so gratifying yeah I
was very very good I actually just set
them a Flames but like out of every like
out of an episode that's like it keeps
you so curled up in tension it is like
such a reward I know but yeah I I'm
definitely uh just for clarification
purposes and I mean it from the bottom
of my heart especially when you could
see that this was all wrong
it's all wrong
team black all the way I mean I don't
you know I like I like uh actually I
shouldn't mention YouTube is so
sensitive about some some words but
there's the CK CH word that uh Allison
drops and talk about rainey's about like
your husband was that and I was like ah
it's nice to hear they used in an actual
definition
yes yeah see where it is yeah gotcha
nice definition word so yeah it's like I
know there's some of course deception
and sort of Lies amongst that but what
stance true is she's the one who's
supposed to inherit the throne bottom
line she's the one and uh this was all
deceitful so yeah 100 team black on this
whole situation
can I be team renice can I can I just go
there
I'm pretty sure she's gonna go team
black yeah this is probably true but
that's what makes a cool character out
of her is the fact that like even though
she was been wronged on all fronts by
everyone it's like the end of the day
the honorable thing well yeah and uh I
guess the target
of a heavy piece of dishonoring right
now is probably going to be the enemy of
my enemy who will now be my friend yeah
yeah it's great writing great writing
overall I'm sure it's a wonderful
[Laughter]
books I'm good too after it's the kind
of thing I'm like it's so much more fun
I feel like it's not it wouldn't be if
I'm sure it's really fun and engrossing
as it as it shows for people who have
read the book and like the way they talk
so enthusiastically and get so emotional
about it the with the backed up feeling
of like you don't even know what's
coming in yeah
every time your mind is blown there's a
game of fans Game of Thrones fan around
the corner waiting to go no just you
wait yeah and just you wait so my I like
being here where I'm like I have no clue
and I love that yeah um I can only
surmise with the information that's been
given to me and I just love watching the
trajectory of these characters I I think
every performer here is so well so well
layered and
um yeah I feel like Otto's the real bad
guy of this whole thing more than all of
them I feel like Auto Hightower is the
real villain well yeah I mean he's this
he seems to have the best blend of he's
very smart very cunning he's able to put
up face and you know dude he's able to
do the court stuff and and do the
presentable ceremonial stuff and then
he's able to do the really ugly down and
dirty stuff well I mean he's not yeah he
does all this evil [ __ ] and he's not
indulgent usually like he got so intense
and you felt that ticking clock by him
that that race against the clock that
was all he feel that just with auto
Hightower
um like he's on the street
like that this guy is this guy is right
now he's like we're on crunch time right
now yeah we only have a few short hours
to solidify our our master plan once we
announce it he's dead we gotta we gotta
announce a nuke in the new error all
right guys thanks for being here this
was an awesome awesome awesome awesome
episode
um you guys rock uh thank you to
expressvpn uh subscribe click that Bell
leave a like last but not least let's do
it
Lord Everett of house Baker you my
friend seem like the kind of person who
probably would die in this world you're
too nice man you're too friendly and
kind to us and uh you know you might
make it by if you were to live by your
namesake like if you were a baker
somewhere in the city not too close to
flea bottom you know where like the kid
fights happen you might make it through
but honestly I'm glad you live in this
day and age with us I don't want to see
you maimed and mangled by the harshness
of the era in the realm and all that
stuff I'm not even gonna mention your
middle name this time it's just Everett
of house Baker because that's who you
are for reals that's the real essence of
you and we are glad that you share it
with us here we're glad that you are
loyal to team orange and red if that's
our colors I guess and and you know our
house Sigil of of the Celluloid we
appreciate you uh swearing fealty to us
and bending the knee and we love you and
we'll catch you uh on the next one be
well always a pleasure
[Music]